bonsoir nouvelle édition en ce mardi 24
février de votre journal d'information
locale voici les principaux titres qui
seront développés au cours de la
prochaine demi-heure le ministre des
Finances à Bazainville dans les Yvelines
en déplacement sur le site de
l'entreprise Chris qui bénéficie du
crédit d'impôt pour la compétitivité et
l'emploi depuis maintenant un an comment
la police surveille votre logement lors
d'une longue absence l'opération
tranquillité vacances sur le terrain
avec une patrouille en activité à Buc et
puis invité Frédéric Dulac mère adjointe
à manielle et hameau délégué au centre
social notamment et nous parlera à des
quinze jours dédié aux femmes dans la
commune et cette information pour
débuter selon nos confrères du Parisien
une femme de 32 ans et son fils de 4 ans
serait porté disparu depuis vendredi
dernier les autorités penseraient que
cette femme d'origine congolaise
demeurant à Guyancourt et envoie de
radicalisation serait parti faire le
djihad en Syrie il est probable qu'elle
est tenté de passer la frontière
rappelons qu'au début du mois le préfet
des Yvelines a donné une conférence de
presse sur la problématique de la
radicalisation violente il estimait que
le département était particulièrement
concerné ce conflit à présent en
politique qui oppose Alexandra rozetti
et Alexis Biet l'ancien mer UMP de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux ne semble pas
digérer sa défaite de 15 voix ou
dernière municipale face à son ancienne
adjoint udi un recours a été déposé
devant le Conseil d'État et pour le
rapporteur public il pourrait être
nécessaire de retourner devant les
électeurs c'est la distribution tardive
d'un tract qui motive cette analyse
délibérée attendue pour le 26 février
qu'en pense Alexandra Rosetti
entend-t-elle se représenter en cas de
nouvelle élection sa réponse c'est au
micro de Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
d'élodymoine
en moins d'un an on a déjà un bilan
voilà des choses à présenter on a fait
des choses on sait où on va
donc je suis voilà après c'est la
démocratie voilà c'est vraiment
l'exercice de la démocratie
ce qui est embêtant c'est que dans ce
cas-là le préfet suspend tout les élus
sans délai et que la ville est gérée
pendant quelques semaines par un
administrateur temporaire donc il va pas
se passer grand chose à voisins pendant
on va dire tout le long du mois de mars
probablement début avril voilà et puis
ce qui pourrait presque plutôt
m'inquiéter c'est l'abstention c'est à
dire que je pense que les gens ils en
ont marre de gens d'histoire voilà c'est
comment est-ce qu'ils vont réagir est-ce
qu'ils vont aller au bureau de vote pour
exprimer à nouveau un choix ou est-ce
qu'ils vont se dire bon il y en a marre
et voilà j'espère qu'ils se déplaceront
parce que c'est ça justement le jeu de
la démocratie Alexandra Rosetti qui
précise d'accepter les règles de la
démocratie vous l'avez entendu quant à
Alexis bet il aurait pu te l'idée et
d'un combat personnel et ne souhaite
pour l'instant pas commenter cette
décision de justice avant que ne soit
connu sont délibérés ce sera donc pour
la fin de la semaine en attendant nous
sommes allés dans les rues de Voisins le
bretonneux afin de demander aux
habitants s'ils étaient prêts à
retourner aux urnes s'il fallait
recommencer cette élection municipale
si le Conseil d'État dit on reste
derrière la vie du Conseil d'État voilà
pour moi non parce que
parce qu'on n'a pas les résultats de de
l'enquête j'ai eu enquête et puis les
gens ont voté s'il s'avère que les 15
voix c'est un peu frauduleux du fait
sans avoir respecté certaines choses
pourquoi pas si on applique la loi si
elle litige parce que il y a eu des
mêmes façons
de beauté les résultats actuels me
satisfontainement je crois que c'est le
cas également de mon épouse donc je ne
souhaite pas moi qui dit à nouveau des
élections je pense qu'un troisième
mandat pour Monsieur Biet ce serait
peut-être un peu beaucoup c'est nul le
nouveau maire a été élu il est élu point
on va passer à autre chose
monsieur
qui passe la main si les mauvais joueurs
les mauvais joueurs
on sera donc en fin de semaine si il
faudra ou non revoter à Voisins le
bretonneux après l'élection municipale
qui s'est déroulée en mars dernier
Michel Sapin le ministre des Finances et
des comptes publics et quant à lui venus
visiter le site de production du groupe
Chris c'est à base d'un ville dans les
Yvelines donc le site qui emploie plus
de 400 personnes et qui bénéficient du
crédit d'impôt pour la compétitivité et
l'emploi depuis maintenant un an à
l'occasion pour le ministre de faire le
point sur les dispositifs de soutien aux
entreprises il y en a Torres et Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude pour ce sujet
15h hier Michel Sapin ministre des
Finances et des comptes publics fait son
arrivée à base en ville dans les
Yvelines là où depuis les années 80 le
groupe chris a installé son activité
industrielle et logistique là aussi ou
depuis l'année dernière un dispositif de
soutien a été mis en place le cice
crédit d'impôt pour la compétitivité
l'emploi grâce à cela le site aperçu
environ 350 000 euros en 2014 et
devraient toucher 600 000 euros cette
année de quoi pousser le groupe à
investir le conseil d'administration de
Chris Group a décidé d'investir 12
millions d'euros pour le développement
de son unité de fabrication de verre
pour faire des verres haut de gamme
augmenter le service aux opticiens et
aussi pour développer l'activité
logistique du site en passant en passant
de 7 millions d'articles transités par
an à plus de 10 millions horizons 2016
développer l'activité c'est aussi
recruter des salariés l'année dernière
une vingtaine d'emplois a déjà été créée
et dans les deux ans à venir le groupe
devrait encore embaucher une quarantaine
de personnes le cice semble alors
fonctionner ici Michel Sapin la
découverte sur le terrain lors de la
visite une visite suivie d'une table
ronde sur les différents dispositifs de
soutien aux entreprises plusieurs
patrons ont pu échanger avec le ministre
j'ai surtout eu des préoccupations sur
mais est-ce que ça va durer longtemps
est-ce que ça va continuer ma réponse
est oui inscrivez-vous dans la durée
c'est un dispositif qui est là pour
faire en sorte que les charges des
entreprises diminuent et diminuent dans
la durée quand on investit on investit
pas pour trois mois ou pour un an on
investit pour 10 ans le ministre là
affirmé les entreprises ont bénéficié de
plus de 40 milliards d'euros de baisse
de cotisation et d'impôts en l'espace de
4 ans
toute autre sujet à présent on connaît
l'opération tranquillité vacances sur
tout durant les périodes d'été des
agents de la police nationale ou
municipale qui assurent la surveillance
des logements dont les occupants sont
partis en vacances une opération qui
dure maintenant depuis un an et demi qui
se déroule aussi tout au long de l'année
nous avons suivi une patrouille lors
d'une tournée à Buc Catherine zulato
Elodie moine
ces agents de la police nationale ont
amusé une opération tranquillité
vacances direction Buc dans le centre
ville
tn 78 je vous annonce que nous nous
rendons rue Louis Blériot à Buc pour une
opération de tranquillité vacances c'est
bien pris pour tel
arrivé sur place les agents débutent
leur tournée par une inspection visuelle
de la maison à surveiller les portes les
volets ou encore le jardin par où un
cambriolage peut s'effectuer
principalement par les fenêtres donc là
ils ont observé que les volets étaient
bien crochetés ils ont observé que sur
la porte d'entrée il y avait pas de
traces d'effraction pas de traces de
pesée ou de tournevis ou autre et
ensuite là il vérifie au niveau donc du
portail que le portail n'a pas été forcé
d'un point de vue juridique on ne peut
pas rentrer à l'intérieur de la
résidence d'accord on reste quand même
dans du dos droit privé donc par contre
ben on observe tout ce qui peut être
observable par rapport à une effraction
avant de partir les policiers laisseront
un avis de passage dans la boîte aux
lettres l'occasion aussi pour eux de
rencontrer la population vous avez rien
de remarqué d'inhabituel concernant
cette maison
depuis un an et demi cette opération
était tendue toute l'année c'est gratuit
et les modes d'inscription sont simples
tes propriétaires de leur résidence
peuvent se rendre au une période police
ou alors tout simplement à la mairie
pour
demander à ce que les effectifs de
police passent devant leur leur domicile
les opérations tranquillité vacances
concernent majoritairement les
propriétaires de maison mais les
résidents d'appartements peuvent
également demander en bénéficier et en
dehors du passage de ces policiers des
conseils de bon sens s'appliquent lors
d'une absence prévenir déjà le voisinage
laisser un jeu de clés tout simplement à
un ami ou à des amis ou à de la famille
en demandant à passer régulièrement la
chose la plus simple c'est de montrer
qu'il y a encore de la vie tout
simplement donc dans la maison les
cambrioleurs interviennent assez
rarement comme ça sur un coup de tête
ils font souvent du repérage si tu as
des boîtes aux lettres débordent pendant
les vacances
potentiel voleur voit que l'appartement
est vide
la première chose sur vider les boîtes
aux lettres en 2014 l'opération
tranquillité vacances mise en place au
sein de la direction de la police des
Yvelines a bénéficié à 733 foyers dans
le département au mois de janvier de
cette année 105 foyers se sont inscrits
au dispositif aucun des domiciles mis
sous surveillance policière a été
cambriolé
loisir en cette période de vacances
scolaires les communes multiplient les
ateliers à destination des enfants à
Magny-les-Hameaux ces ateliers sont
organisés autour de la thématique femme
du monde lundi se tenait un atelier
autour de la peinture au pigment naturel
de quoi faire découvrir une autre
manière de peindre aux enfants Mélanie
pocket et le dimanche pour les images
ces artistes en herbes découvrent
aujourd'hui la technique tempera une
technique utilisant les pigments
naturels des épices comme le curry le
curcuma mais aussi de l’œuf l'intérêt
c'est d'inventer la propre couleur pour
que justement ils redécouvre le plaisir
des matières et aussi comment sont
fabriqués les couleurs à l'origine
qu'ils apprennent en s'amusant et qu'ils
ne soient pas juste à utiliser des
peintures des tubes achetés en grande
surface on peut utiliser vraiment toutes
les matières même certains légumes comme
la carotte la betterave pour obtenir des
choses plus proches de l'aquarelle une
fois les palettes préparées les enfants
peuvent découvrir cette technique
utilisée à la fin du Moyen-Âge et au
Quattrocento le 15e siècle italien
et j'ai fait des points et un coeur pour
que ça décore autour ça donne des
couleurs qu'on connaissait pas avant
c'est rigolo
et on crée des nouvelles choses si les
enfants sont ravis c'est aussi le cas
des parents la tempera n'utilise que des
produits naturels c'est intéressant
parce qu'il y a pas de produits
chimiques et deuxième femme deuxième les
enfants même et peuvent les mettre dans
la bouche ça risque rien pour la santé
et tout des arguments qui font que même
quand on est tout petit on peut s'y
essayer
et pour continuer à parler de cette
thématique Frédéric du lac bonsoir vous
êtes la mère adjointe déléguer au centre
social au CCAS à la santé cette
animation famille que l'on vient de voir
s'inscrire en fait en amont d'une
semaine dédiée aux femmes des îles ça se
tiendra du 2 au 8 mars l'idée d'une
semaine dédiée aux femmes c'est pas
nouveau sur la ville ça existe depuis
quand et dans quel objectif ça fait une
bonne dizaine d'années
et si vous voulez on a commencé par
faire d'abord il y avait la journée de
la femme après il y a eu la semaine et
maintenant puisque ça ça tombe souvent à
la fin des vacances scolaires la semaine
cette semaine là du coup on en profite
pour faire une semaine en amont avec les
familles avec les parents les
grands-parents qui souvent gardent les
enfants leurs petits-enfants pour faire
un peu dans l'intergénération et ça
permet aux enfants aussi d'aborder des
sujets
avec leurs grands-parents ou avec leurs
parents qui n'ont pas l'habitude
forcément d'aborder une réflexion sur la
condition des femmes
de la gym de la relaxation etc
évidemment c'est ouvert aux hommes aussi
bien sûr ça commence à s'organise une
telle semaine une telle quinzaine s'est
fait avec les associations de la ville
vous sollicitez des partenaires
extérieurs alors il y a trois services
municipaux qui sont
qui travaille dessus avec le centre
social parce que c'est le centre social
qui est porteur du projet mais il y a le
service culturel le service des sports
je ne sais plus lequel entre mes trois
les trois centres sociales sport et
culture il y a 8 institutionnels ou
intervenants extérieurs qui mène les
ateliers qui mènent les débats parce
qu'il y a des débats des expos des
débats des films
cinq associations au moins parce qu'il y
en a souvent qui qui se qui s'approche
enfin qui reviennent à chaque année sans
préparation spéciale mais qui nous aide
et puis alors tous les bénévoles qui
c'est très très important ça fait partie
des temps forts de la de l'année
à Manille comme ça des temps forts qui
sont organisés par la commune et qui
vraiment crée vraiment du lien et de la
fédérateur effectivement chaque année la
thématique parce que on vous le disait
pas la première année que cette organisé
autour de la semaine de la journée des
femmes la thématique des îles cette
année alors cette année c'est les
îles sur la route des îles alors c'est
ça va aussi bien de la Guadeloupe les
DOM-TOM français mais il y a tout il y a
Cuba il y a tout ça il y a aussi le
choix s'est fait comment comment vous
élaborez vous décidez après chaque
semaine on fait avec tous les services
et toutes les associations nous faisons
un bilan et pendant cette réunion bilan
on essaie de trouver un thème pour
l'année suivante voilà cette année
c'était les îles alors bon il y a un
moment où il va falloir ça va être
compliqué parce que là on a fait un peu
le tour
Asie Afrique Amérique etc donc Europe on
a fait l'Europe l'année dernière donc
bon c'est un peu compliqué mais on va
trouver on va pire on peut changer c'est
pas on n'est pas obligé d'aller sur la
route d'un pays ou d'un continent vous
parlez de l'intergénérationnel il y a
aussi cette question de rencontre entre
les communautés entre les cultures aussi
puisque là c'est les îles donc ça permet
aussi de mélanger les cultures de
s'ouvrir d'autres cultures tout à fait
d'ailleurs le l'affiche de qui annonce
cette semaine a été composée par des
photos de Magny quoi venant des îles qui
ont donné des photos de famille et donc
c'est alors c'est un petit c'est on voit
pas très bien il faut regarder
attentivement mais on pourra reconnaître
des manicois qui ont bien voulu prêter
des photos
de leur enfance ou de leur grand-parents
ou voilà donc il y a une visée sociale
je reviens sur ça en parler fabrication
mais il y a une visée vraiment sociale
pour assurer et de réflexion sur les
conditions féminines
partout dans tout sur tous les
continents et voilà donc il y a beaucoup
d'animations le programme complet est à
retrouver sur le site internet de la
ville de Manille mais quels sont les
temps forts alors les temps forts bon il
y en a il y en a beaucoup mais il y a le
mardi alors je ne connais pas je me
rappelle plus des dates le 3 je sais
plus pour les gens retrouvons sur le
site internet mais en tout cas les
événements
avec trois courts métrages sur des
une femme qui défendent leurs droits qui
comment les femmes défendent leurs
droits alors c'est en Guyane on Haïti à
Madagascar donc c'est des approches
similaires et différentes et puis alors
le samedi soir il y a parce que c'est le
7 je crois que le 8 est un dimanche le
samedi soir il y a le concert de Maya
kamati c'est alors on l'appelle la perle
de l'océan Indien voilà moi je connais
pas du tout je vais découvrir avec tout
le monde et ça permettra aussi avant ce
concert de de faire monter sur scène des
habitants qui ont fait pendant la
semaine un atelier de danse
de
Kira avec ce thème là avec cette
chanteuse donc voilà ça sera très encore
participatif par rapport aux différentes
éditions combien de personnes sont
touchées sur cette sur cette commune à
travers les animations alors écoutez
c'est très là j'ai pas les chiffres je
dois dire
je dirais entre 1000 et 2000 personnes
uniquement de Magny-les-Hameaux est-ce
que c'est ouvert aussi aux extérieurs
bien entendu simplement il faut
téléphoner au centre social pour
réserver sa place pour dans les ateliers
dans tout ça il y a une randonnée par
exemple le dimanche 8 une randonnée avec
une association manicoise et là c'est
c'est illimité comme petit détail
pratique aussi puisque on le disait
c'est ouvert à tout le monde mais
combien ça coûte est-ce que c'est payant
les animations sont financés comment non
qu'une chose qui est payante et je ne
serai pas vous dire laquelle tout le
reste est gratuit absolument gratuit on
a des aussi des
exemple le pivoie qui
le bailleur social qui participe
toujours très
attentivement et qui est toujours avec
nous pour ce genre d'opération là des
animations qui sont prévues dans le
cadre et de cette semaine cette
quinzaine autour des femmes tout dernier
rendez-vous si un rendez-vous à ne pas
manqué votre coup de cœur à vous pour
conclure oh le le les courts métrages du
mardi soir avec parce que avec un débat
après avec une personne du cdff qui va
venir nous mener ce débat etc donc la
condition féminine c'est quand même le
centre de de cette semaine merci d'être
venu sur ce plateau pour évoquer cette
mobilisation cette quinzaine amanilamo
merci à vous on termine avec un peu de
sport à présent ce week-end vient de se
tenir elle encourt les quarts de finale
de la Coupe des Yvelines de futsal un
moyen de découvrir cette discipline qui
se passe à l'intérieur et vu la météo en
ce moment c'est plutôt une bonne idée
ce n'est pas l'hiver qui les fait
pratiquer à l'intérieur c'est
footballeurs de moins de 12 ans joue
aujourd'hui leur place en demi-finale de
la coupe des Yvelines de futsal si pour
un œil peut avertir rien ne semble le
différencier du football traditionnel le
futsal a tout de même ses particularités
les règles principales de futsal donc il
y a pas dehors je
les touches se font au pied le gardien
il doit dégager à la main et non au pied
comme se fait dans le foot traditionnel
pour les touches et le ballon posé
arrêté sur la ligne de touche 4 secondes
pour le jouer et le gardien quand il a
le ballon dans les mains il a eu lui
aussi 4 secondes pour le jouer
le
niveau fronté pendant 10 minutes par
match lors des demi-finales ces jeunes
joueront 13 minutes de quoi devoir créer
une dynamique de groupe faut laisser une
équipe
je collectif
les vicinois et élancourtois de moins de
12 ans sont sortis vainqueur de ce
plateau ils joueront les demi-finales en
avril prochain
et je vous redonne cette information
pour conclure ce journal selon nos
confrères du Parisien une femme de 32
ans et son fils de 4 ans serait porté a
disparu depuis vendredi dernier les
autorités pensaient que cette femme
d'origine congolaise demeurant à
Guyancourt et travaillant sur
Montigny-le-Bretonneux était en voie de
radicalisation elle serait partie faire
le jihad en Syrie il est probable
qu'elle est donc tenté de passer la
frontière avec ce pays rappelons qu'au
début du mois le préfet des Yvelines à
donner une conférence de presse sur la
problématique de la radicalisation
violente il estimait que le département
était particulièrement concerné c'est la
fin de cette édition du mardi 24 février
je vous retrouve demain pour un nouveau
point sur l'actualité local est dans
quelques instants pour le 7 8 politique
une édition dédiée principalement aux
élections départementales très belle
soirée et à demain